[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con dado que la
variante delta causa nuevos picos de
contagio en todo el mundo varios países
se han motivado a aplicar dosis de
refuerzos y dosis adicionales de vacunas
contra el joven 19 aunque los términos
son percibidos como iguales no son lo
mismo hoy en la consulta con nuestro
asesor científico el médico colombiano
carlos eduardo pérez vamos a aclarar
cuando si y cuando no se requiere otra
inyección para protegernos del virus
doctor bienvenido a france 24 en efecto
una dosis adicional no es lo mismo que
una dosis de refuerzo porque ya que
poblaciones se dirige cada estrategia
lo primero valentina es que las dosis de
refuerzo son las personas inmuno
competentes es decir a las personas que
no tienen problemas de defensas que la
mayoría de la población mientras una
tercera dosis se coloca es a las
personas que tienen alteraciones en su
sistema inmune y que por causa de
medicamentos de su propia enfermedad van
perdiendo la inmunidad y es necesario
una dosis adicional para que esta
inmunidad permanezca en el tiempo
bueno usted mismo estaba mencionando los
refuerzos no están recomendados para
todas las vacunas y tampoco para todas
las personas por ahora los centros de
control de enfermedades sólo aconsejan
para los inmunosuprimidos que recibieron
pzifer o modernas sobre johnson y
johnson aún no hay anuncios porque sólo
aplican para estos laboratorios
básicamente es por los estudios clínicos
y los estudios clínicos hablan de eso
hablan de una dosis adicional no habla
de un booster o refuerzo eso todo está
por evaluar cuál será el mejor momento y
qué tiempo y con qué estrategia si es
con una misma o con diferente vacuna por
ahora las dosis adicionales se colocan
en personas inmunocomprometidas
porque son las personas que están
perdiendo la inmunidad mucho más rápido
que lo que hace una persona
inmunocompetentes
doctor la organización mundial de la
salud volvió a insistir en que no hay
pruebas suficientes de que una dosis
adicional proteja más a los ciudadanos e
hizo de nuevo el llamado a que los
países ricos no acaparen estos
medicamentos es realmente necesaria esa
dosis adicional que debe según la
organización mundial de la salud deja
sin suministros a los países en
desarrollo que ni siquiera han podido
completar el esquema recomendado de dos
dosis
digamos que la bbc es el llamado de la
dosis de refuerzo que hemos hablado que
es en esta población inmunocompetentes
donde no se ha establecido todavía cuál
es el mejor momento las dosis de
refuerzo que es en esa población que es
un pequeño pigmento del segmento de la
población que simuló comprometido si se
requiere pero obviamente mientras en el
mundo en todo el planeta no hay una
pauta completa seguirán circulando las
variantes y estas vacunas de primera
generación es probable que pierdan su
efecto por eso la tercera dosis no puede
volverse otra asimetría social e
inequidad de una repartición de las
vacunas desde su visión ética se
convirtió la administración de vacunas
en un negocio para las farmacéuticas y
para los países desarrollados que se
puede hacer para que esta balanza se
equilibre
si parece totalmente injusto que las
vacunas se repartan por las fuerzas del
mercado económico y no por la necesidad
de las personas la solidaridad para que
todos nos vacunemos es la única forma de
evitar la circulación del virus
estrategias como liberar las patentes
promover que se hagan las vacunas y se
ensamblen en diferentes países tener
muchas más alternativas disminuir los
costos son una estrategia para que se
masifique la vacuna si no nos vacunamos
todos va a persistir la circulación y
nos demoremos más en superar la pandemia
doctor ya se ha mencionado en algunos
momentos que se necesita un porcentaje
de más o menos 70 o 75 por ciento para
superar la pandemia pero realmente este
porcentaje puede funcionar con las
nuevas variantes que están circulando
no y esa es una gran preocupación porque
la variante delta requeríamos una
vacunación superior al 97 98 99 por
ciento para lograr la línea colectiva
estas nuevas variantes ya alteraron
completamente el porcentaje de 70 a 80
por ciento ya no ha no aplica y es
necesario que nos vacunemos todos es
decir que ya no hay una inmunidad
colectiva sino la población se
distinguirá en la población vacunada y
no va con nada pero no podemos
colectivamente proteger a los están
vacunados doctor pues a usted muchas
gracias por este análisis y a ustedes
por continuar con nosotros en france 24
recuerden que tenemos más continúen
nosotros
[Música]